hey I the concept of AI it's something
that I think we're all familiar with
thanks to numerous amount of TV shows
movies and novels for me personally I
find this to be sort of a tired concept
at this point you just seen it so many
times in sci-fi and especially the idea
that AI is going to take over we've seen
it in Terminator but I also seen this in
some of my favorite work of fiction like
a Space Odyssey open the doors
I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do
that
some of my favorite novels like I have
no mouth when I'm with scream don't get
me wrong I find it a very interesting
concept even though it's overused but
when Stephen Hawkins in 2014 came out
and said my mind sort of went Stephen
Hawkins what do you know about anything
okay
do you watch Rick and Morty because I do
and I think I have a little better grasp
of the universe concept ideas like AI
thank you very much Stephen but stick to
your science stuff all right
the concept of AI taking over it's feels
so far off because it seems so obscure
the way it's portrayed in Hollywood
movies or in the work of fiction but in
reality it's actually I think or from
what I've learned an actual threat the
idea that Johnny Depp could come back
and kill us all it's not as far away as
we think
my god it's that my mind has been said
feeling despair I need more power
but how did we come to this conclusion
I'm gonna try and explain okay but I
truly don't know [ __ ] well of what I'm
talking about so please if we take it
back a couple steps a lot a couple steps
there's this game of tic-tac-toe that I
found that no matter what input you make
you will the computer will never let you
win it's kind of [ __ ] annoying it's
programmed with algorithms so that no
matter what move I make and it was
exactly what moved to counter it to make
sure that I can't win no matter what not
a big deal
not a big deal okay in 1958 a che Simon
and Alan Newell AI experts but what if
you take a more complex game than
tic-tac-toe say chess for examples
there's a lot more possible outcomes in
that game first saw that within ten
years a digital computer will beat the
world's best chess champion now it
didn't take ten years not until 1997 you
may have heard of this it was quite the
big deal at the time deep blue became
the first computer that was able to be
the reigning chess champion at the time
casparo
but it's clear that the computer will
reliably do what he himself would do and
he recognizes that he has already lost
on deep blues 19th move the champion
resigns
now it still doesn't seem like that big
of a deal and basically the way
deep-blue worked was that it would scan
every single possible outcome it could
make about 200,000 per second and it
would make the best decision based on
what he could find through through this
method of scanning at this point I'm
still like Stephen Hawking I've seen the
videos of the machines falling over okay
I think we have nothing to worry about
but here's where I think it gets
interesting in March 15 2016
the champion of the Chinese board game
go was beaten by an AI against alphago
the artificial intelligence designed by
google's deepmind it was a resounding
loss they had won only one game alphago
wins we landed it on the moon so proud
of the team respect to the amazing lee
sedol too now the reason why this is
such a big deal is that in chess you
only have so many options but in go
there are so many different moves that
you can make that there are more
possible moves that you can make then
there are atoms in the universe and
there's no way that you're going to be
able to compute that amount of options
to figure out what's the best move to
make so how did they make this it may
not seem like that big of a deal either
but it's really cool okay it's really
cool it basically uses deep
reinforcement learning which is similar
to how we learn as humans through trial
and error reward and Punishment and raw
inputs say if we see something ourselves
the computer figure learns itself how to
become good at the game not too long ago
there was a viral video of from
sethbling that uses method to teach a
computer to play Mario and it became
really [ __ ] good at it really good at
it
look at that basically a used neural
networks to learn how to play the game
which is similar to how we think as
human beings and with enough computing
power you could simulate a human brain
in this way but we're not there yet but
it wasn't good from the beginning it had
to learn how to get good get good in the
beginning it doesn't even know where
has to go or what the option is or what
Mario is but eventually it figures out
it needs to move right but through
different generations and learning and
from trial and error and adapting from
these mistakes it eventually becomes
better and better and the similar method
was used for the alphago program where
it would train against itself slowly
becoming better and better and better
and eventually a master at the game
there's a super cool video about a robot
that doesn't know that it has limps but
it teaches itself how to walk despite of
this so it's just doing random movements
it sort of figures out it has four limbs
but it doesn't know where those limbs on
its body is attached and by trial and
error it eventually figures out where is
limbs are positioned and eventually it
can very graciously move across that's
cool self learning AI is really [ __ ]
cool and there's a lot of advantages
that you can do from this using it in
design for example this is a 3d printed
cabin partition that's been designed by
a computer it's stronger than the
original yet half the weight and it'll
be flying the Airbus a320 later this
year
so computers can now generate they can
come up with their own solutions to our
well-defined problems so then with Elon
Musk as well as Stephen Hawking saying
AI could become a problem in the in the
future that idea starts to sort of make
more sense to me knowing this is how it
works I think we should be very careful
about artificial intelligence if I would
guess at what our biggest existential
threat is it's probably that Elon Musk
as well as Bill Gates chiming in as well
with the same idea that evolution has
endowed us with and it's funny in
slow computer very limited memory size
ability to send a man to other computers
this mountain air and but it's also
whenever we bear a new one and it
doesn't know how to walk three tries
yeah so believe me as soon as this
algorithm taking experience and turning
it into knowledge which is so amazing of
course we have not done in in software
as soon as you do that it's not clear
you'll even even know when you're just
at the human level you'll be at this
superhuman level almost as soon as that
algorithm is implanted in Siliguri bill
basically here come it compares how our
brains as a computer our method of
evolving is very inefficient with
comparing it to how AI would be evolving
and exponentially growing and knowing
and keeping that in mind humans are
inferior
without a doubt that being said not
everyone is on board with this idea that
AI is going to take over or that it's a
problem for the future what are your
thoughts on AI and how it could affect
the world you know I have I have pretty
strong opinions on this I'm really
optimistic right I'm an optimistic
person in general I think you can build
things and and the world gets better but
with AI especially I'm really optimistic
and I think that people who are
naysayers and and kind of try to drum up
these doomsday scenarios are I just I
don't understand it I think it's it's
it's really negative and it and in some
ways I actually think it's it's pretty
irresponsible yeah hey Elon Musk
responding on Twitter I've talked to
marked about this his understanding of
the subject is limited hi mom Mark
Zuckerberg obviously I love the suck
more than anyone it's kind of hard to
take him seriously on the subject
especially since he clearly is trying to
make an AI himself good morning mark
it's Saturday so you only have five
meetings
room temperature is set to a cool 68
degrees
I guess what Mark is saying it's a I can
do a lot for us as humans it can benefit
us greatly and I think what Elin points
out is that there are dangers involved
with the development on this and we need
to be careful how can we protect
ourselves from ourselves we are an
intelligent adversary we can anticipate
threats and plan around them but so
could an super intelligent agent how
confident could would be that the a I
couldn't find a bug like given that
merely human hackers find bugs all the
time I'd say probably not very confident
like disconnect Ethernet cable to create
an air gap but again like merely human
hackers routinely transgress air gaps
using social engineering like right now
as I speak I'm sure there is some
employee out there somewhere who is
being talked into handing out her
account details by somebody claiming to
be from the IT department we should not
be confident in our ability to keep a
super intelligence genie locked up in
its bottle forever I'm actually fairly
optimistic that this problem can be
solved like we wouldn't have to try to
write down the long list of everything
we care about or or worse yet spell it
out in some computer language like C++
or Python like that that would be a task
beyond hopeless instead we would create
an AI that uses these intelligence to
learn what we value and his motivation
system is constructed in such a way that
it is motivated to pursue our values or
to perform actions that it predicts that
we would have approved of computers
smarter than human beings is inevitable
if you keep in mind how short we have
even had technology and our presence in
the universe
now whether AI will be something good or
or destroy us all in the future that's
just for us to find out meanwhile you're
gonna have to excuse me because I have
some Rick and Morty episodes to catch up
on I hope this video was educational and
I hope I didn't say any wrong things
because I sure AM no expert
thank you for leaving a like on this
video if you enjoyed I really appreciate
it make sure to sucscribe and as always
squad fam am